years after the peak of his visibility
Tony Hawk is still around at 51 might
think he's slowing down a bit easing
into a quiet retirement perhaps in fact
Hawk is as busy as ever with
philanthropy conquering the fashion
world and much more for a huge swath of
kids teenagers and sad the adults at the
dawn of the new millennium Tony Hawk
defined what it meant to be awesome but
today the man behind the board is as
much into his family as he is into the
halfpipe his son Riley Hawk was born of
his first marriage in 1992 saying at
first people thought it was kind of
strange that I was kind doing the skate
thing - two more boys Spencer and Keegan
were born of a second marriage and his
first daughter cadence clover was born
in 2008 Tony Hawk married once again in
2015 and now lives comfortably in
California Hawk might be older now but
his love of skating pervades his home
life his eldest son Riley has become a
celebrated skateboarder in his own right
on his 21st birthday Riley went pro and
won the best am award within minutes
today he sponsored by Baker skateboards
and has become respected as a street
style skater in contrast to his father
one of the most celebrated vert style
skaters of all time
cadence also pops up regularly on Hawks
Twitter and Instagram channels learning
the basics from the world's most
accomplished teacher
Tony Hawk has become increasingly
involved in charitable work over the
years in 2002 he created the Tony Hawk
Foundation an organization that
facilitates the building of public skate
parks across the United States focusing
specifically on the needs of low-income
and other disenfranchised areas the
Foundation has awarded 7.9 million
dollars in funds to date the breadth of
the mission is startling every part of
the country has been marked by hawks
quest to make skating accessible
respected and safe in all communities
recently Hawk spearheaded a campaign to
take the foundation global with a
$50,000 grant to skate a stand an
organization that works to bring skating
to Cambodia Afghanistan and South Africa
in 2015
Hawk told ABC 10 News skateboarding is
empowering women in Afghanistan more
than probably any other sport to me
honestly
in 2007 Hawk helped found athletes for
Hope which fosters connections between
the world of elite sports and young
hopefuls more than 10 years later
they're still going strong Hawk has been
a hot commodity in the entertainment
world for decades over the years he's
played himself on The Simpsons appeared
in kiddie fare like rocket power and
taken bit roles and action flicks like
deck dogs oh and don't forget his cameo
in the 2005 film Lords of Dogtown where
he played an astronaut who wipes out on
his skateboard
more recently Hawk popped up on the
popular YouTube hit Epic Meal Time and
he even made an appearance on Sesame
Street back in 2008 skateboard for
wheels on a skateboard morning also we
would be remiss not to mention his star
turn in the Aquabats Super Show
what was it like being thrown in outer
space we were in outer space skate
culture has been influencing the fashion
world for a long time from Avril
Lavigne's stylings in the early 2000s to
the classic vans off-the-wall sneakers
skating and fashion have always seemed
to go hand in hand it was only a matter
of time before an actual skater took
that relationship to the next level Tony
Hawk did this with the Tony Hawk
signature line a collection he debuted
at Paris Fashion Week the line is an
upscale take on skater style as
envisioned by one of skating subcultures
most legendary heroes talking to Vogue
Hawk weighed in on the success of street
wear brands like palace and supreme
noting how they're being recognized and
embraced by a much bigger crowd people
who want to have that look but who don't
necessarily skate in 2019
he told heist nabiyya t if we reach that
level I want to join into because I feel
like I have enough to offer and I have
enough history Hawks career coincided
with the rise of the Internet so it
makes sense that he would jump headfirst
into the world of original video content
this is my first skateboard ever and
we're sending it today to the
Smithsonian and I would give it one last
try answer the right channel Hawks own
little corner of YouTube which he
launched in 2011 here you can immerse
yourself in all things skating and skate
culture as Hawk says in the welcome
video we're super excited this is
something that we've always wanted to do
and it's finally reality and it's here
on YouTube and so you should go
subscribe right now ride has a dizzying
lineup of programs there's concrete
dreams a documentary webseries about the
challenges of skatepark advocacy and
there's lots of nitty-gritty reviews for
the latest skating gear if you prefer
like a slimmer shoe that you don't have
to hold like this then you probably
shouldn't get these what makes the
channel so great it's not about the cool
factor it's about the reality of the
sport I'm gonna kick everyone out check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]